[Music]
ariana grande
making her first appearance as a missus
it's the most fun i've ever had in my
whole life on thursday the pop star
hopped on stage to help the weekend
kick off the iheart radio music awards
performing a sultry duet of their chart
topper
savior tears
[Music]
this was ariana's first public
appearance
following her wedding nearly two weeks
ago
where she tied the knot with luxury
realtor dalton gomez
and all eyes were on her stunning
wedding band throughout the performance
ariana also earned four nominations at
this year's ceremony
her track with lady gaga rain on me
nabbed two of those nominations
dance song of the year and best music
video
[Music]
in addition ariana's fans or orionators
earned her a spot in the category for
best fan army
while she was also up for female artist
of the year
[Music]
and thursday's big night comes just a
day
after ari gave us our first glimpse of
her new bling
i'm happy life is good on wednesday
ariana shared
these intimate photos of her wedding to
instagram
taking fans inside the private affair
starting with her getting ready before
the ceremony
all the way until she and dalton said i
do
earlier this month a source confirmed to
e.t that ariana and dalton had gotten
married in a small
private ceremony the source added the
couple wanted the ceremony to be
private and took precautions to make
sure that happened
the ceremony started in the afternoon
and went into the night
ariana and dalton are ecstatic and look
forward to their future together
ariana and dalton made their
relationship public in may
of last year in ariana and justin
bieber's music video
for stuck with you